donnie
what's up man welcome back how you doing
doing great how are you doing this
question
i'm
i'm better than ever dude i'm actually
12 days clean off of fentanyl and
i've got my family back uh my son's here
today um
i
i'm just so positive dude like i can't
even
i can't even begin to explain like
i want i want to get into motivational
speaking and i want everybody to
know my story and like how far i've come
and just
how proud i am of that
you should be you should be i mean to
take so much responsibility for
everything that you've done
i mean i never thought in a million
years like i would even get clean i
thought i was gonna
i thought i was gonna be like a sad
statistic you know i mean like like wind
up
dead in a public bathroom or something
you know like horrible like that
you know i just
i'm glad i get the second chance to be a
you know better role model to my son and
you know like get
just get that opportunity
you know i mean how old are you now i'm
33
33
yes sir you're still a young man yeah
you know i still got all the time in the
world to you know make that change you
know it's just um
i want to
like i was always told like if you want
to
succeed and like
you know i have to change my i have to
change the people i hang out with i have
to change
you know everything about myself and
i've been a pretty good failure up till
now so now i'd like to be a you know
i'd like to be a you know pretty big
success if i can
yeah and and your path might be a
crooked one but it
as long as you're helping some other
kids i think they could be great
definitely i would say that's a fair
assumption yeah you know my my story is
a little uh
colorful to say the least but you know
what if uh if i could reach anybody and
you know help them to detour like
the you know horrible decisions i made
i'm i'm all for that
do you see all your decisions or a lot
of your decisions that you've made in
your life as as do you see them that way
horrible
well i'm
definitely definitely uh
drug-induced decisions were not not a
good idea
you know it led to
you know i could
i could say that addiction like ruined
the
you know good part of my life
you know and now
now i'm just trying to just mold it back
together you know
keep my family you know together now and
just try to
not be not be so petty like i was you
know what i mean like i used to just
argue about dumb things like things that
didn't matter you know what i mean like
until
until i got
homeless on homeless by myself is one
thing
but when i had my family out here with
me dude like that
that's when the real responsibility set
in you know what i mean i was like oh my
god my son you know he has to eat every
day you know i've i can't have him
around you know junkie friends of mine
you know i'm not
i'm not talking you know bad about my
friends but
i mean
you know we all know like we're not
you know the most suitable for you know
underage kid you know i mean like so
you're willing to tolerate for yourself
is one thing but what you put your wife
and kids through absolutely he's very
different absolutely yeah
and you know like i've been
like every every little bit of money i
get dude is now to you know just to make
sure that they're all right like you
know i had a
i had a bad falling out with my
relatives
which was where we were staying and
it
it it put me out by myself
you know i mean like and
i just realized like how
how not ready i was like
i mean if it
i for one oh
i owe a big thanks to my girlfriend
who locked me in the room and you know
like
held me down like like even
even threaten me with violence if i
leave you know what i mean like
and um whatever it takes
yeah yeah she did that for me and i'm
you know forever grateful for that so
you're on suboxone now yes
yeah 12 days now that's great that helps
people
yeah it really does it's a miracle
you know i thought i thought methadone
was like the
the way for me and
i realized now that that was just
another means to an end like suboxone
was the way to go
you know i mean because now i can
approach my days from
the the not sick standpoint you know i
mean like i don't
like i hated waking up every day and
before i even open my eyes i'm already
thinking about my fix you know i mean
like that's that's horrible you know my
son's waking me up and wanting to play
with me
and
i'm thinking about just getting high
like that
yeah i mean like so what do you think
helped you make the change
realizing that
the ones that i have close to you know
that i hold dear to my heart now
are what was really important and i kind
of back burnered them
you know
for
a long time and
[Music]
i think suboxone just
opened my eyes
you know like realize how selfish i was
being and how like how just not good of
a dad i was being
you know like me and my son have a great
relationship but
i haven't been always the best role
model you know and i know that
it's interesting to see someone who
hears someone who looks like you do
face tattoos and you know all the other
crap you've been through to to to be
speaking so clearly
you're so clear-headed now and you see
things like yeah yeah that's the
craziest part for me is like i was just
so clouded with like
just
no thoughts of the future of any kind
you know i mean and just just
like wasting away pretty much you know
what i mean like i was just
like trudging along i guess you know
until like until something bad happened
but
you know thank god i realized you know
ahead of time
that i mean drugs weren't what was going
to make me happy my family is what's
making me happy like so you're
optimistic now for your future
absolutely
the love i have for my son you know is
something i want to
in some way give back to
you know
i want
i want to get into motivational speaking
and like on a big stature i would love
to
i would love for anybody to you know get
in contact with me that could point me
in that direction of
you know if anybody thought that i
changed their lives in any way hearing
my story the first time
[Music]
i mean i would
i would love to reach as many people as
i could
what do you think the secrets are to
walking a straighter path to living a
better life
for you or for other people going
through similar things
well i like first i
i said you know i wrote down goals you
know like like
realistic ones you know like what what
do i want like within the next um
six months
you know i wanted uh i put i put down an
apartment
um a vehicle
um
you know a job
you know um
[Music]
i put like four or five things down but
you know i mean but they're all like
realistic goals that i mean
now that i'm now that i'm sober i can
actually
i can actually try to reach these goals
but i realized dude i don't know the
first
i don't know how to buy a house
you know i mean like i don't
i don't
i
i don't know how to be a grown-up have
you had a job
huh have you ever had a job no
no i mean i mean
like under the table like like you know
street positions yeah
really yeah two artists or something
like hey you know i mean but
yeah
like
yeah i've never had a you know
legitimate job never you know worked the
nine to five and
you know never earned a paycheck
basically
so i mean all this is new to me
like
you see that you deserve something
better than what you've
been given yourself right absolutely
like i can't believe i
ah dude like i'm actually embarrassed i
let myself you know like
that i've you know like
went as far as i did was it tell me
about your childhood again
just you you
you didn't come up from
the best circumstances well yeah i mean
you know my mom uh
my mom you know was an addict in uh the
early years of my life and my dad was
always in prison
you know um
my mom she did the best she could you
know what i mean like and
you know i mean
i just try not to have any
like i have no hard feelings towards you
know like them not being there
you know what i mean like um
[Music]
like there's no bad blood there it's
just um
we don't we don't even speak really and
not because i'm angry i just um
i don't know i guess i'm just i'm just
you know wrapped up in you know in my
life trying to figure it out as they
were i guess you know
and now that
now that i'm an adult myself i try to
i try to put myself in in their shoes
and i realize now it's
it wasn't as easy as all that
you know i i probably made some hasty
decisions and like you know
about my about my feelings towards my
family
but
i mean all in all i mean i
they did
they did the best they could
yeah i mean but after doing all these
talks i've learned that shame is a huge
factor in all these stories
shame on your parents part for what they
did or didn't do
shame on your part for mistakes you've
made
but forgiveness
absolutely erases it all yeah i think it
leaves room for something good to happen
absolutely
yeah forgiveness is the biggest thing
for me like i don't want
i don't want to have any like
any like harshness of any kind in my
heart you know now like i
you know growing up
growing up surrounded by
you know
violence in the streets um
uh
you know fast you know fast-paced living
you know with drugs and you know quick
money and all this like
i used to think that that was like the
hollywood you know like like that's like
the rock star you know lifestyle and i
mean
like it's all well and good if you're
like actually the rock star you know
what i mean like otherwise you're
just [ __ ] oh
you know and i think i'm
i'm a pretty like good like poster child
of like you know that up till now
you know i like
i like that like
i've shown that i can be an a1 you know
[ __ ] up but
i want to also show that there's more to
me than that that
i have
that i know i actually have something to
say and that like
you know like
i want to know that like my existence
mattered in some way
you know what i mean yeah
that's great
how important is
your
inner like deep belief in what you
deserve in life
a factor in all of this
because when you were getting all these
face tattoos in prison i assume
you probably didn't believe you deserved
a whole lot better than what you were
getting
right and now you seem to speak very
differently yeah you know in the
beginning i've
i kind of felt like
when i first had my accident and i went
to prison
you know doing my term and i felt like i
was never going to go home i kind of
felt like i was going to get wrapped up
in the system and
wash myself up you know i mean and never
see the light of day again
you had no hope
yeah
pretty much and then
i don't know man like the years went by
dude and
all of a sudden i'm gonna get released
and i'm like
i'm looking in the mirror and i'm like
oh my god
like what did i do
you know what i mean like and i never
noticed it before like because when
you're in prison
face tattoos and things that are common
i
i got a rude awakening when i got out
after five years dude and i was the only
tattooed face in the room
you know what i mean like i felt like
everywhere i went that
all eyes were on me like
and you know
in the in the good sense and the bad
you know i mean because like
it made me like you know like oh god
like
you know like i feel like people were
already passing judgment on me and you
know what i mean like for the way i look
and
i mean i just realized that
the way i look
isn't gonna define me
i want
i want the message that i have and uh
the things that i
stand up for in my heart to you know
like things of substance that matter
you know i want to be remembered for
that and
you know like i think that's why i could
actually like help
you know young and up-and-coming kids
that are just you know a little troubled
and you know maybe
because i think i don't know i'd
probably be
a good help to them because i'm i'm not
the kind of person to sit there and say
hey
don't do this you know don't do that and
you know tell you why
you know i can just be like
you know hey do it
but
i did it and this is what i got for it
you know i got a wheelchair and a whole
you know a whole bunch of tears and lost
years
yeah no but you're able to smile now
you're able to see things better yep i
realize now that families families
forever and
with with my girl and my son in my life
i feel like i could accomplish anything
i really feel that
you know that i could have the
you know white picket fence lifestyle
and you know like that
you know
if my life is ever a book that you know
it can be like looked as a success story
you know like
you know like we can all come from
turmoil and like or just go through
turmoil and you know come out on top did
talking on my channel help you see
things different
yeah ever since ever since meeting you
dude has changed my life and
i can't even explain to you how positive
way really yeah
yeah i when i first when i first you
know when i first met you and uh we did
the first interview i
i had no idea i you know i
i'd never even heard about it you know i
mean like i didn't know who you were and
then
like
i just um
you know like i've seen on uh you know
on youtube how like you know you talk
about like how you created you know how
you created soft white underbelly and
like just
like i don't know dude like i was like i
was like fascinated and like i was like
man like like i want to be like that
dude you know i mean
like no but the talk helped you see
things better or more clearly absolutely
absolutely you know hearing hearing
people's um
you know in the comments and the
comments were very positive too right oh
yeah man like that that
that changed my life dude like i i've
read every single you know every single
comment and there's thousands of them
you know i read every single one and
you know i took in like every every one
of them you know i mean like and thought
about it and like you know like how much
i appreciate like
the fact that somebody even wanted to
listen to my story and
you know how grateful i am to you that i
get to even tell my story how grateful i
am that
people wanted to listen to it and wanted
to hear more that it touched them that
you know like
just that i could be uh
just so that i could be a positive
anything to somebody is
i'm i'm really happy with that
you know um
getting getting sober is a scary thing
because
it let me realize how empty my life was
like how like
like meaningless my life was like you
know like to me
like all i cared about was
getting high
and
and i didn't
i didn't see the damage that it was
doing to me or my family
and
you know i just
it's scary i'm learning how to be a
grown-up for the first time
and that's
that's real brand new to me
can i bring your son in absolutely let
me go grip yeah
i'm so proud of him
he's the top of his class man he's so
smart
what's up baby
who's this
this is my son eddie
say hi baby
hey eddie
tell them your name
my name's edward
hey edward how are you
good are you happy that your dad's
getting his life together
yeah
tell me about your life tell me about
your dad
my dad
feeds me good food and he's he's your
best dad ever i had
and
you don't have to like no you can tell
him how dad really is like i mean
do you love dad is he your buddy yeah
yeah uh-huh
your best friend yeah
is he there for you yeah
do you love him uh-huh
i love you too
cute
eddie thank you so much for
coming in saying hi
donnie i'm proud of you thank you very
much man stay on the right track yes sir
keep it up we'll do another
maybe uh update
who knows maybe you get some speaking
engagements
i would love it dude i i welcome all the
positive you know feedback i can get
you're you're a pretty great example of
somebody who's trying to transform their
life and they appreciate that i really
appreciate you saying that
you know i
it feels really good to
to matter in
in anybody's life especially
people i know and complete strangers
it's it's awesome
all right you guys thank you very much
say bye buddy bye
you